claude malhuret bonsoir est-ce qu'on
doit appeler ministre les droits de
l'homme ou secrétaire comme on veut
c'est quoi le vrai titre phare et it est
un peu long c'est secrétaire d'état
auprès du premier ministre chargé des
droits de l'homme des droits de l'homme
se dire droit de pas très bien florence
belkacem bonsoir c'est bien nick
novembre
soit parce que des chanteurs encore
peiné gagné dans ma vie à chicaner mais
j'ai encore eu des problèmes physiques
j'ai failli pas jouer il vous faut pas
croire samassa mali permis dans le
désarroi total
ce que je veux dire j'ai eu des crampes
au niveau de l'estomac et à nice est
descendu en bas c'est pas évident je
veux dire bon parce que je suis beaucoup
trop bas les gels ému ce qui se passe
beaucoup trop vite
bon c'est vrai que je me suis un mètre
90 89 kg bon mach une et comme sa
cheminée gros ça t'arrive à tout ce que
je peux dire c'est que pour des
problèmes physiques
je suis là pour parler de raciste parce
que bon c'est vrai que je suis pas noir
je pas blanc non plus enfin chez moi je
suis pas très clair c'est vrai mais ce
que je veux dire à la recherche d'une
identité est bon je compte en deux par
les racistes maintenant car sinon les
week-ends georges wolinski vans warped
est déjà venu aux bains où ça ici était
déjà venu à n'ont jamais c'est la
première fois
c'est à dire tu as fan peu d'aidé là
parce que maryse est au courant maryse
est au courant mais c'est surtout elle
ça ma fille qui la dit rov quelle chance
tu as mal vient avec la prochaine fois
prochaine fois je ramènerai philippe
guérin bonsoir alors claude malhuret on
va commencer par toi est ce que j'ai lu
dans un journal que tu as été baba et
que j'avais les cheveux longs sur les
épaules c'est vrai quand j'en avais
quand on avait et maintenant tu gardes
que les moustaches à souvenirs des
années 60 les cheveux j'aurais du mal à
les garder mais
de toute façon dans les années 70 je
crois que j'étais pas le seul à être
baba avoir les cheveux longs on était
beaucoup moins tu as fait et les
moustaches c'est comme un souvenir les
années 70 oui parce qu'à l'époque
j'avais les moustaches et la barre
depuis j'ai rasé la barre mais par
contre wolinski lui tu as vu il se
laisse pousser la barbe
ça fait un an et demi il adore tant est
content oui parce qu'à voir à la télé je
trouvais j'avais peut-être comme un
ballon de recrues alors ça casse un
petit peu le rythme cette donne un genre
c'est vrai voilà oui ce que tu as pu sur
la tête tu là aujourd'hui c'était ma
dernière chance d'avoir un genre voilà
maintenant tu es un grand champ deux
itinéraires qui se croisent pour en
parler tout à l'heure oui alors clos de
tuer docteur vraiment tué et huit mètres
sans quoi et bien médecine tropicale et
puis et biologie médecine légale a passé
beaucoup de temps dans le tiers-monde
une dizaine d'années avec médecins sans
frontières mais quand on est spécialisée
en médecine tropicale c'est une
spécialité difficile à exercer ici alors
évidemment je l'exercé ailleurs ouais
mais si quelqu'un s'évanouissent et là
parmi nous tu serais si yannick avait un
malaise par exemple ils sont capables
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il vaudrait
peut-être mieux prendre le téléphone et
appeler sos à bord il a perdu parce que
c'est vrai quelques années quelques
années gage que j'ai eus tennis tu sais
tu as perdu la main probablement oui on
perd vite la main dans ce métier si on
arrête et ça fait quand même quelques
années que j'ai tu as fait de mettre ça
moi monsieur le ministre je vais pas
vous poser une question sur le pen mais
par contre je voudrais vous demander une
chose pourquoi est-ce que vous n'étiez
pas là la fameuse nuit chaude
l'assemblée nationale où le groupe du
front national a pris un peu en charge
l'assemblée parce que ça aurait été
fantastique pour vous vous seriez reçu
une baffe là parce que à la députée rpr
qui s'est fait bousculer sur le feu
effectivement mais je n'y étais pas
parce que tout s'est passé un petit peu
par surprise dans la soirée d'ailleurs
la soirée s'est calmée au mieux que sa
première à redémarrer au milieu de la
nuit il y avait un seul ministre
présente et et albin chalandon quelques
députés la plupart étaient retournés
comme ils le font tous les week-ends
dans leur circonscription et le front
national a d'ailleurs ça vtt août
moi j'étais chez moi je crois ce soir
c'est pas aller bosser quoi mais je ne
ne suis pas la radio heure par heure
pour savoir ce qui se passe à
l'assemblée nationale et si front
national va décider dans ces guérillas
il avait décidé de le faire justement ce
qu'il savait c'est un moment où il y
avait moins de plus haut tu que tu
connais ce bouquin je viens de le c'est
extraordinaire alors ça c'est alors
wolinski bon le connaît mais jérôme
duhamel est ce que c'est le troisième
frère duhamel le tout parce qu'ils
arrêtent une fois chirac a dit j'ai fait
un cauchemar
j'ai rêvé qu'il y avait trois duhamel
nice ne s'est pas le troisième lui non
non c'est le petit la deuxième elles
décrivent eux qui on a complètement vous
lis jamais d'accord que l'on connaît
alors que les batteries sans connaître
on connaît plus l'écrivain
on se dit toujours je vais lui c'est le
fils de georges duhamel deux petits fils
et petit fils
l'idée a fait plusieurs livres l'idée du
livre c'est absolument génial c'est que
donc c'est tout les pourcentages ça va 2
1% à 100% alors lui pivot il m'aidait
des signes et nous on n'est pas en ouvre
au hasard 68% des français sont
favorables au père noël par exemple il
ya des choses complètement ils sont
happy des 18% des français font la
sieste le dimanche voilà mais c'est
quand on les prend absolument géré
ensemble quand on les lit les unes après
les autres que ça devient drôle
ouais donc il faut tout lire faut
l'acheter le full picorer clicquot il ya
un truc qu'il ya un truc est très
étonnant là dedans c'est qu'on dit après
à valérie et charlie hebdo wolinski
dessine notamment pour libération et
nouvel observateur et un coude
il ya un trou alors il faut qu'on en
parle c'est tout je suis désolé si tu
vas nous expliquer pourquoi tu parles
pas de l'humanité annoncé pour moi je
sais pas pourquoi ils l'ont pas vu
pourquoi moi ce sont des années qui ont
été très heureuse deux années que j'ai
passées alors là je vais prendre mes
petites notes parce que j'ai retrouvé
des choses que tu as dis quand même à
l'époque où tu étais à l'humanité je
suis désolé de te faire ça georges
meylan tire pas des olives menteur faire
ça parce que je t'adore
mais c'est pour choquer malhuret alors
tu as dit le goulag est ce vraiment
important
je te demande pas de répondre à chaque
fois su me tu peux répondre en bloc à la
fin tu as dit l'urss un pays qui tente
une expérience le goulag assurément
importance à me tourner jeudi 5 août
c'était
malheureusement dans l'urss un pays qui
tente une réserve allemand important
actuellement monde après l'afghanistan
je déplore mais je ne condamne pas à
j'ai dit des choses pour tous à l'est
les juifs s'ils ne sont pas contents en
urss ils peuvent partir ben moi je pense
qu'ils devraient de football d'accord
cuba ce pays respire l' envie de
s'amuser c'est vrai oui
non mais je sais pas moi je te disent
que non mais c'est vrai j'y suis tu
trouves pas terribles ils disent des
trucs comme ça parce qu'on l'a d'or en
plus voilà ce qui nous fait marrer on va
parler tout à l'heure c'est ses trois
nouveau nés de nouveau bouquin de bandes
dessinées qui sont en question géniaux
mais alors enfin je continue dans l'huma
le seul journal au net
à l'époque j'ai dit ça oh mais c'est de
la provocation ouais non mais c'est ça
que je te demande et alors c'est un
désir de teu teu diaboliser comme ça de
devenir aragon devenir patrick besson ça
je pense par marc mais non ça m'agace et
parce que il ya des tabous qu'on veut il
ya des choses qu'on n'a pas le droit de
vivre on n'avait pas le droit de dire à
l'époque où moi je suis allé en ss et
j'ai fait un article dans lequel je ne
disais pas c'est un paradis que je
disais que c'était pas non plus un enfer
à l'époque c'était un tabou il fallait
absolument dire que l'urss était un
enfer or maintenant j'ai bien marrant
déjà il ya eu des articles aussi bien
dans le figaro que ailleurs où on disait
que quand même il y avait une vie qui
était vrai pour certains côtés peut-être
plus intéressante que celle qu'on peut
avoir la mairie ouais tu préfères l'urss
aux etats-unis mènent maintenant c'est
trop ça va je ne connais pas je ne
connais pas les états unis mais il est
certain que j'ai
je serais plus inquiet dans les rues de
new york dans les rues de moscou ouais
ça dépend si on s'était dit c'est dans
la rue l'usiné grand les rues de la
havane aussi je crois on peut se
promener tranquillement dans les rues de
la havane
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de
villes d'amérique du sud moi je pense
que tu m'as dit tout à l'heure que je
faisais plus d'interviews juste et mais
dis-moi pourquoi tu as dis ça au fond
sérieusement pourquoi tu as fait toutes
ces déclarations à l'époque parce que je
le pensais mais tu le pense toujours
je vais te citer georges pompidou ouais
j'ai pas les gaullistes ils ont beaucoup
donné dans le procès viêt et j'espère
qu'en de mentir ouais parce que je fais
trop de choses vraies et en 25 ans si
j'étais menteur si j'étais pas sincère
et si je disais finalement des choses
tellement ignoble je crois que je
détesterais plus pas compte des tests à
montador j'étais déjà les trois fois
dont les gens font la part des choses
vont faire la part la provocation
et puis aussi la sincérité et puis aussi
de la vérité parce que ses doigts c'est
est salutaire de faire ça et moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'il faut parfois dire
des choses moi j'étais en invité à
l'ambassade de à cuba ouais et les
diplomates qui étaient là nous disait je
me disais on fait des rapports dans
lequel sur la situation à cuba dans
lesquels on dit que c'est finalement pas
si mal ouais et ses rapports sont
censurés à paris parce qu'on nous dit
faut pas dire ça mais qu'est ce qu'on
pense malgré toi moi j'ai dû arrêter au
psu et est maintenant parce que c'était
occident c'est ce que j'allais dire
j'essaie de relativiser les choses parce
qu'il ya 15 ans j'étais dans les rues en
train de manifester et dire vietnam laos
cambodge vaincrons et j'ai participé à
ce qui est lancé aujourd'hui
depuis je suis allé à la frontière du
cambodge en ethiopie en afghanistan et
là il est certain que leur désaccord un
tout à fait d'accord et pas du tout
d'accord avec ce que je disais donc je
suis modeste et pas du tout d'abord est
ce que dit aujourd'hui
wolinski cela dit il est normal de ne
pas être d'accord ou à cuba ou en urss
georges wolinski dessinateur célèbre
effectivement peut se promener sans
aucun problème mais cuba est le pays du
monde où il ya le plus de prisonniers
politiques ont maintenant on va parler
de deux autres livres de wolinski sont
aussi bien d'ailleurs c'est dd 5 1 qui
s'appelle gaston l'habite et autres qui
s'appelle bonne année ils sortent tous
les deux en même temps tellement
l'habitude sortie depuis trois mois
ouais je dois dire que le premier en
parler avant un repas quand même il ya
encore quelques
réticences quand un livre d'une grande
santé moi je trouve ça drôle oui depuis
je ne pense qu'à ça je trouve que tu
tiens une ligne alors on a demandé à on
a demandé à gears à notre force heure
locale de nous faire un petit sujet
justement pour détendre l'ambiance pour
nous montrer un petit peu alors explique
moi j'ai trouvé les chiffres effrayants
dans ce clip 100 % de français
moi j'ai juré vous quand vous serrer la
main aux gens vous avez cette chance sur
100 que la personne se soit gratter les
fesses avant par ces terribles quand
vous êtes en visite officielle ou pire
encore il ya 5 % 6 % des français qui
ont déjà fait l'amour au cinéma alors on
est parti de ces conclusions pour voir
un peu comment les français réagissait
au tournage d'un film pornographique
on a repéré on a demandé à un coiffeur
un café et un restaurent un restaurant
pardon si on pouvait venir tourner un
court-métrage
on s'est installés on a pris un comédien
une comédienne et puis petit à petit on
a fait comprendre qu'en fait c'était pas
du tout un court métrage mais un très
bon sens métrage on en bas mais alors
mais là on a deux caméras vidéos c'est
une passe en boucle les images toi
tellement ça
ok
[Musique]
prenez votre temps
allez viens
c'est marrant c'est marrant c'est sur
quoi
ça court métrage ouais enfin chaud
chaud
oui
[Musique]
donc vous faites la scène de la
rencontre
tu hésites pas toi tu es les avis assez
rapidement mais lui tu te laisses
habillée pour le voeu au départ la
comédienne va se mettre nue donc ça
risque de poser des problèmes quand même
prévenir les gens éventuellement ça
dérange personne ou la comédienne va t
on des repas
les caméras
les albanais découvre et après tu veux
pas céder quand même non kas est grand
c'est un verdict non assisteront et
possédera bref mon écran voilà
comme ça
qu'est ce que on vous met un verre non
vous risquez de voir le renverser et à
vous montez vous monte lentement la
scène vous commencez par tu toi tu
commence discrètement pas bien
cash et actions
je
oh
au fait vous êtes
pourtant vous arrête on sait que c'est
un vous m'avez donné aucun scénario rien
du tour
je vous ai dit que c'était une rencontre
will est d'accord laissez-vous carte
ouais vous arrêter là où pose problème
parce que ces problèmes
c'est gentil il n'y a pas de ça vous
choque non ça vous pose problème par
rapport aux casses et voilà c'est tout
mais c'est pas un film porno c'est une
rencontre érotique environs a dû tout de
vous m'envoyez et on peut pas arriver un
accord en prenant est arrivé un accord
mais dans le la scène en enlevant la
scène un peu trop vous m'en voyez
quelque chose vous
on reprendrait un rendez vous je ne sais
pas pour vous arrêter d'accord d'accord
mais ça vous choque pas pourquoi c'est
inspirant tv futur des sables oui bien
sûr c'est rigolo c'est d'abord et avant
tout ça avant qu'on vienne pouvoir faire
ça de pouvoir montrer ça à la télévision
moi je trouve c'est bien quand même sauf
que quand même depuis 1960
bon ça vous avez dit j'ai bien que vous
avez été utile j'ai un peu cette petite
qui atteint les arrêter un des deux ce
qui a aidé à ce que l'on puisse voir sa
sont sont criantes y voit la preuve
c'est qu'on le montre à des ministres
qu'est ce t'en pense claude à moi je
fais qui vont je crois que wolinski a
beaucoup marqué jeu ce que je qui m'a
surtout marqué en 60 c'était la reine
des pommes c'est pas
le reste depuis j'aime beaucoup mais
inscrits mais je l' ai découvert à
l'époque du début d'hara-kiri dans la
reine des pommes et
ce qui était vraiment une bande dessinée
fantastique avec un style très différent
de celui qu'il est aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus chargé beaucoup moins dépouillé
mais
c'est la réussite est vraiment les
couverts et toi yannick alors moi ça me
fait penser qu'on fout 6-3 6-2 à cécilia
c'est vrai travail mais avec cécilia ça
va pas fort mais quand même mais n'ont
pas aimé l'attitude sur la chanson
reggae c'est son problème je suis qu'est
ce qui se passe je vais pas aller à un
pétard veut faire partager
enfin bon je veux dire on refait sa vie
je fais la mienne et puis ces conditions
ne véhicule a quitté tu gagnes est ce
que tu vois qu'il récession de sauzet
les faits c'est possible mais bon là je
gagne beaucoup plus je veux dire au
niveau physique parce que bon là là
c'est vraiment été bon c'est que je que
je mets est ce qu'avec ces six-là bon
c'est des petits jeux des s'était pas
tellement intéressant et puis blond
c'est rare que je fasse des jeux gland
ce moment et ce que je veux dire c'est
que le bon salle manque aussi de ce côté
parce que je pense que ça commence
ça y est à la halle aux sports à
l'apport des corrections de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux